okay let's start
welcome to the edps seminar today before
we introduce today's speaker let's go
over some
rules and logistics first of all
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have
questions so that our speaker can
talk without unnecessary interruptions
if you have clarification questions you
are welcome to unmute yourself and ask
those questions
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in q a session at the end
second no classified discussion is
allowed here
so watch out finally the talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our
youtube channel okay
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
um it is an honor to
host today's speaker excuse me
dr goyal who is from max planck
institute he graduated from the
department of
engineering design at
indian institute of technology
in 2003 2013
he then joined the department of
professor peter banner
at the max planck institute for dynamics
of complex
technical systems in germany
for his phd in 2018
he received his phd in mathematics at
the autobahn
greek university of magdeburg
in germany again he has been a
postdoc for the period of 2018 to 2020
at the mpi dcts
magdaberg germany again since 2021
he is the team leader of
physics-enhanced machine learning
in the csc csc department
at the same institute dr goyal's main
research interests are scientific
machine learning model order reduction
physics enhanced learning of dynamical
systems
and image reconstruction today dr goyal
will present physics-informed learning
for
non-linear dynamical systems a deep
learning approach to
operator inference which is aligned with
our core interest here so we expect a
great talk today
and now without further ado let me pass
the button
to dr goyal dr boyle it's all yours
okay thank you very much for the kind
introductions and it is
my pleasure to be to be here and present
some of our work
which we have been doing very recently
in our department
and so i'm also happy to present our
our recent work in this seminar and
looking forward for some fruitful
discussions later on as well
so today i will be presenting some work
on the physics inform learning for
nonlinear dynamical systems and
basically in this
work we have focused on operator
inference approach
to learn dynamical systems before i
go further so i would like to first
thank
all my collaborators with whom i have
worked and
and to present some of the joint work
and which includes peter banner karen
wilcox
benjamin festovar boris kramer ego
pontus and highland
and bullet karazhan and suleiman yadines
and so the main focus here
what we are looking into modeling
dynamical models
for processes and why we need dynamical
models is to analyze transient behavior
under the operating different different
operating conditions
and for example if you want to design a
control for a chemical plant
for example you want to avoid some
disaster in your plants and you want to
function your plant according to your
desires and you want to
implement a control strategies
or if there is a parameters you want to
optimize the parameters and want to
predict
long time horizons for dynamics and for
this all purpose we need
dynamical models so that we can carry
out our engineering
design studies
so let's look up the what are the main
things so
you are giving a physical systems and
the physical system might come from the
for example mechanical systems or for
the networking or electrical circuits
and etc etc and these are the physical
models which has been studied
for more than a decade and these are
very well studies
one of the thing is if you if your
process which is very well understood
there are probably partial differential
equations which
are very well known for example in
incompressible flow there is a neighbor
stocks
and which can describe the flow
of inflow in a given domain
moreover on the other side which you can
see is that
a physical system might carry some
expertise
and some knowledge which can come from
our experts or
experimentals and these are probably
there is no laws which we understood but
from the experience by expertise
there is a model which we can write
which will describe the physical
or physics of a particular process
and then we will end up in the
differential algebraic equations and
other side
which we can also end up in the
differential algebraic equation if you
discretize
a partial differential equation
and once we have this algebraic
differential equation then you can use
that model into simulation control and
optimization or uncertainty
quantification etc
whatever your desire is but however
there are two main
bottleneck in the whole process which i
want to highlight here and
there's two tooth measure concern point
is a discretization step so
how you really would discretize such
that the all the dynamics are captured
in
in your model and the second thing is
the high fidelity of the models
and which can also cause some concern to
us
so let's dive into these two concerns a
little bit more details so
the first challenge is again the
discretization for complex process the
discretized model
which describes all the underlying
dynamics and features is a challenging
task so
if a given domain and if the comp and
the process is
very complex then you want to discretize
in such a way that
all the dynamics is very well captured
and all the features of the process
and this this becomes even more
challenging and demanding if
if your geometry is more complex
involves multiphysics as well
and there is a coupling between the
different components for instance
and then this all the process becomes
even more cumbersome and the last thing
which i would like to highlight is
is the case where you do not even have a
access to a discretized model so for
example consider the case where
you are giving a legacy code to to
simulate a particular problem or
that is very dedicated simulator toolbox
for instance
and if you really want to get a
discretized model then you have to
really understand what is
the code is doing and how these matrices
are assembled
and which may not be an easy task for
for an end user for instance and this
code
generally always has on the regular
times updates and
you have to again see what has been
changed in the code so that you can get
again discretized model and this process
also can be very cumbersome
and second point which i i would like to
highlight
is the high fidelity models and if you
if your dynamics is very complex then
and to resolve all the dynamics and the
underlying dynamics you need to have
a lot of degrees of freedom which will
describe the dynamics and which is also
called like state space dimension which
can easily
go up to ten power four or ten power six
and if you have a such high fidelity
models then simulations or repeated
simulation and control and optimization
becomes very infeasible
so these are the two two challenge which
we have in front of us
and we would like to resolve this
to come around with these two issues
so again i would like to like sketch out
so
so in the end what we want to have is
if you want to get in a model for
example which
describe the dynamics of a process so we
typically go
through these four steps so first you
are giving a partial differential
equation with a boundary condition which
you want to have it
and then the first step which we do is a
model and what we do is again
discretize the model and which will lead
to high fidelity models
and we if you want to do control and
simulation with this high frequency
model and to
to ease this task we want to get a
reduce for the models so these are
typically as a flow of the work which we
typically follow
so as i said it these are the two steps
which is one is discretization and this
high fidelity models
can we go out of these two steps
so what we want to do is that we
are giving a partial differential
equation and we are we want to get
directly reduced for the models but
this this process is reversed by the
fact to collect the data
and we are giving a data set which
simulates
or which are obtained by the simulation
of a partial differential equation
but we do not have access to a
discretized model
and we or these are the process which
you want to avoid
for instance so as aesthetic the data
can be
obtained for example from a commercial
software or legacy code
and this this steps or this software
does not allow us to
dig into discretization or how these
things are discretized or we
do not want to do these things because
it's a cumbersome task to get a
discretized model directly
or out of from the out from the software
or from a code
and so and our goal is to get a same
reduced order model which you
if you would follow this path partial
differential location and discretize and
high fidelity model and then reduce all
the models and this reduced order muscle
model can be get directly from the data
so if you are giving a data which
simulates a partial differential
equation
and if we can get directly the same
reduce order models which we'll get from
this path
and one of the advantage of this this
approach would be that
the all the analysis which we have
obtained for example error bounds and
the convergence analysis
for this path can be directly applied to
this path
but now we can skip these two steps
which are kind of a discretization and
the high fidelity
to obtain the high fidelity models
so a little bit dive into
the approach which we typically do to
get a reduce for the models
so you are giving a high fidelity model
which is x dot is equals to a x
and f of x is a non-linear term and we
want to get
a reduced order models which are in the
low dimensional
and typically workflow which we have is
that this high fidelity model is
projected on the low dimension
using the project sense matrix v and
to obtain the v matrix and the common
approach is a
proper orthogonal decomposition which
actually looks
takes the snapshot of the x at the
subway time instance and apply
singular value decomposition to get
dominant modes
and this will give you a very good
approximation
of the high fidelity state into low
dimensional
and then once we have this and matrix we
we can apply
reduced order models or we can opt and
reduce order model by projecting
the high fred lit model in into low
dimensional using this projection matrix
and as we can see it if you want to get
this reduced order models we need the
matrix a
which is a discretized model
or this which can be obtained from the
discretization of partial differential
equation
and this f of x also we need it
and as we said it we want to avoid
computation of this the full matrix a
and f of x as well
so this rise to the
one of the frameworks which we are
interested in and this is operator
inference
framework and the operator inference
framework allows us to construct reduce
order models directly from
data this was the approach initially
proposed by benjamin fresco and wilcox
in 2016
and the operator inference actually is
the approach which makes
use of non-physical structure at the pde
level
we do not uh look into the descriptive
discretized version but only look at the
partial differential equation level
the how this structure will look like
and for simplicity
here i assume this parsing differential
equation other in quadratic form
and which actually if you were to
discretize this partial differential
equation which are in the quadratic form
you will get
this kind of form and
then if you want to construct and reduce
order models then
what we typically do is collect again
the snapshot of the
high fidelity state vectors in the
different time instant
and com determine the projection matrix
using the dominant pod basis
and construct the reduced state by
projecting
the high dimensional state into low
dimension using the v
and then also once you project the
the high fidelity high fidelity state
into low dimensional and then we also
compute the time derivative of this
small dimension here so these are the
all the steps to in the preparation of
the data set
here as you see here is we only make use
of the data
of the state but we do not touch this
high fidelity model on discretized model
then we compute the reduced order models
of the quadratic form by solving a
directly an optimization problem so
let's assume that you
you want to achieve or reduce our models
which are in the quality form
then we can
solve for this operator a hat and h hat
directly
by solving an optimization problem so
then we will get a reduced order models
directly you know
using the data set and we do not require
the any any point of time the full order
models
or high fidelity model in the
discretized space we just need to
simulate
simulated data at the different time
instance
and moreover it can be also shown that
the
this optimization problem and the
reduced order models which we get
by solving this optimizing problems
recovers these new
intrusive pod models if the data is more
focusing
and as a result what we have is all the
analysis
and the error estimates directly from
the period
reduce order models
and typically i would just wanted to
highlight one point is that
typically these kind of least square
problems are ill conditions and hence
we need to regularize these problems and
this has been studied
in the um by the mercury and also by us
and to how to regularize this so that we
get a meaningful solution and
and we can elevate this problem of
inconditioning
so these are the one of the things
which assumes the very particular
structure which are in the quality form
moreover we have studied also in where
we don't do not restrict ourselves to
quality form but we can also consider
a general nonlinear systems
and where the non-linear term is given
by f of x
but the assumption which you make here
is that
we know the form of f of f t of s
so we do not know um in the discretized
form but we only know at the partial
differential
equation level and our goal is to learn
reduce order models directly from the
data
without discretizing this non-linear
partial differential equation in this
form
which and then f of x or the reduced f
has a
almost similar structure which is in a
partial differential equation
and this also in the similar framework
by solving an optimization problem we
can directly obtain
the reduce of the models using the data
in this form
without requiring a discretized model as
as an intermediate step
and we also can use this hyper reduction
to
further accelerate accelerate reduce
non-linear systems and
this is actually you can apply hyper
reduction one of your favorite methods
for example eim or dim or
gnet for instance so
here was so far for the operator
inference and we have applied to various
applications these things
and one of the applications which are
present here is a
table tabular reactor model this is a
single reactions which is a coupled
equations
and these are phi and the and the theta
which denotes the concentration
and temperature and we are interested in
the output
quantity and what we only know is
partial differential equation
we and we do not want to have a
discretized model and directly
uh get a reduced order modulus direct
from the data set
so we what we do is we collected
snapshots of phi
and theta in the time interval 0 to 30
and
look at the decay of
decay of the similar values of the
training data set
and we observe a very steep or rapid
decay of single values which
allows us to construct and reduce order
models of the very low dimensions
here we we consider we try to learn a
reducer models
only order 10 and
we we compared with the if you were
giving a reduce
if you were giving a discretized model
and project in the classical pod setting
and what we observe is that you can also
learn reduce order models
almost as good as pod model without
requiring
requiring a discretized model in the
intermediate step
and here also we see the trend only the
model for
0 to 30 and we predict from the 30 to 60
and the predictive capability of the
both reduced water models are also very
good so that
it kind of tells us that we are not over
fitting the system
and one more example which we have is
coming from
batch chromatography is a chemical
process which is a mixture of
two compounds with a and b and what we
do we our goal is to separate
the a and b from the mixture of two
products so
and the process follows
a particular kind of uh
the process is done generally done in
the columns and this
column has a very special property so
what we do is we're feeding
the mixture of a and b and this is
passing through the
on the columns and but in the columns
that come
the the product a for example will move
faster than the
product p and in the end of the channels
you will actually collect
the the separation of these two products
and this is a kind of a separation
um process which is followed in a
comical cross chemical
processes to to separate the
the products from a and b for instance
so and the dynamics of this process is
given by the best chromatography which
is also again a coupled partial
differential equation
and and it is couple for instance
and our here is also our goal is to to
preserve this coupling structure in the
reduce order model so
so that we don't mix these two uh
two quantities with c and q which
kind of denotes the concentration of the
compounds a
and b in a particular form
so here if you want to really preserve
this coupling structure what we can do
is we can
apply a block diagram projection so that
we do not mix the quantities
and so that the reduced space of the all
the quantities are
reduced independently without mixing
them
so here again we up we compare with the
intrusive pod and and we also learn
reduce order model directly from the
data
and we see the we observe that
both reduce order modus performs very
good and on the one hand we
in the if you want to apply intrusive
pod models then you need to have a
discretized model but
wherever if you want to learn a reduced
mode directly from
operator inference then we do not
require this intermediate steps there
and we can directly
compute reduce order model directly from
the data
also we can also extend this this
operator inference approach for a
parametric case and we have also
if you have a parametric partial
differential equation then you can
directly
learn reduce order models which also
have the same parameter dependencies
and so here we take example of the
shallow water equations which is also
parameterized by the theta which
actually
uh indicates the angle corresponding to
latitude
and this is again a coupled partial
differential equation where you have the
u and v which are velocity and h is a
high field
and we want to construct a reduced
models
for the shallow water equations without
having access to a discretized
version of this cello water equations so
for this one what we do is we
collect the training data set for the
five different parameter settings
in the range of pi by 6 to pi by 3 and
we infrared
reduce order models directly from the
data of order 75 for instance
and we compare the for example the
height field for the parameter
pi 5 pi by 24 which is not in our
training sets
which is on the testing set and we see
this
the comparison of the full order models
and the
reduce of the motors for these
parameters and in the eyeball knob they
looks
very similar to each other so here the
advantage here is the reduce order mod
is directly constructed
from the data without having a
discretized version
in as intimate step
okay so this was i presented so far
is a reduced sort of models how to
construct reduced models
using the operator inference and though
so far we have not considered a
particular find
type of structure or the the partial
differential equation which might have a
constraint
so let's look into how this framework
can be
tailored to constraint non nonlinear
dynamical systems
so so far as i said it we have
considered a
operator inference for non-new system
which are not subject to
constraint but many processes may have
algebraic constraints
involved and one of the application
which we are looking into
is incompressible flows uh and the
dynamics of incompressive flow can be
given by the incompressible navy stocks
equation
where the algebraic constraints are kind
of a divergence
of the velocity field and this is
actually the constraint
and so far we have not
actually have done or have treated this
algebraic constraint
very particularly so let's look into
a little bit more in details how we can
make use of this algebraic constraints
in learning um our reduced order models
directly from the data
so just to highlight a few points so
this
this incompressible navier stokes
equations which are coupled
coupled equations in the velocity fields
and the pressures
and again the one of the thing is
there's a constraints which are kind of
for the divergence of
in the divergence of the velocity field
so
if you were to discretize a nav stocks
equation for incompressible flows you
will have
this kind of discretized form so
you have and differential equation in
the velocity
and then there's a constraints here and
these are again the
coupled so here you have the velocity
field and the pressure
which are actually coupled let's say it
here and
there are some properties of if you
if you get a discretized navy stock so
one is like this e1 one
will be a positive definite matrix and
this also this matrix will be
non-singular and
which actually tells us that if you do
not have these non-linear terms then
this linear part of this nav stocks is
actually index two system
so and in the rest of the talk i will
consider actually in
this g of t which is sitting here is
actually 0 but if you do not have 0 then
also you can treat
by some modification which we have
discussed in our paper but for the
simplicity in the
talk i will assume that g of t here is
zero so if you are given if you are
given a discretized model and if you
want to compute a reduced sort of models
for
incompressible or discretized version of
incompressible navy stocks
and if you construct a reduced model
directly from the pod proper orthogonal
decomposition
so what as a first step what we do is
com
determine dominant pod basis for
velocity and pressure which are denoted
by this vp and and vb
and construct a reduce order models
using the block collecting projections
and you will construct
you will um if you
if you if you put this vv and vp in the
block form and
use the collecting projection you can
directly get a reduce set of models
however if you not these things that the
reduced model which you'll get in the
classical
setting will be independent of pressure
and therefore
and the one of the reason why you will
be independent of pressure is this
vp i think this would be the transpose
here but vp times
a a12 will be actually zero and that
therefore the reduced modulus will be
independent of pressure
and if you really are interested in the
pressure field in the classical pod
setting you cannot get it
so these are the some of the
observations and if you
make analogy with how you really do with
the
if you construct a reducer model using
pod however i just wanted to mention
that
they are of course the setting or the
their treatment to get a pressure fills
in the modified pod settings
but in the classical setting it is not
not possible to get a for example
pressure field
so here our goal is to construct a
reduced sort of models
directly from the data sets so you are
giving velocity and the pressure
fields for the different time instance
and
and we want to do these things with
going through a discretization so for
example if you are giving a
as legacy core to which simulates a flow
and we want
for income so flow and we want to get
reduced models directly from the data
set
so the first observation which you make
is that
that this they all those um
discretized navy stock are coupled and
but using by making use of projector we
can
decouple these equations so to do these
things so
look at this constrained equations and
if you take the derivative of it
we will again get this constraint or
this equality here
and if you substitute v dot from this
equation then we can directly get the
pressure field
or pressure here which is given in terms
of
velocity only and note that here the
velocity
and the connection between the velocity
and pressure is algebraic
there is not even a dynamic so if you
are giving a velocity field you can
directly get a pressure field
and if you substitute this pressure
again in this
differential equation then you can get
an
evolution equation for the velocity
which is actually independent of
pressure and which is actually this one
here
so you you do this analysis if you were
giving a discretized model
but the lesson which you learn here is
that the velocity field
can evolve independent of pressure field
and the pressure
is an e pressure can be given in the
algebraic equations
in terms of velocity field itself so
these are two main observations which we
can make
from our analysis if you are giving a
discretized model
and we use this this knowledge in
learning
reduce order model directly from the
data circle
so for this one what we do is let's
prepare our
data set so you take the snapshot or the
training data set for the velocity and
pressure and the you for example can be
a control input
and again for like in the classical
operator inference we
determine the pod basis for the velocity
and pressure which
actually will project the high fidelity
vector of velocity and pressure in the
low dimensional
and we also approximate
the derivative of the reduced velocity
and once we have this data set we
we can learn a non-intrusive way reduce
order models for incompressive flow of
this form
so as we as we discussed in the last
slides that
the velocity field can be given
independent of
pressure pressure so this is what we
have it
and the pressure actually will can be
given as an algebraic equation
in terms of velocity only and we can get
this operator
directly by solving this optimization
problem and this square problem and we
will get
directly operators of the reduced order
models
so and let's look at
how this works in an experiment so we
have
a cylindrical wick example and
which is and for this which actually
and the flow is controlled and this
boundary here and we we observe the flow
in the in the domain here and we have
collected 513 snapshots in the time
interval from 0 to
two seconds and we learn reduce order
models
of order 30 from these snapshots
so we look up the pressure field which
is actually in the average pressure in
this domain in
some point in the i have not marked here
but this is a domain here in this domain
we look at the average pressure obtained
from the full order models and operator
inference
and we we see that in our training data
sets from the up to
like we split the training into up to
here so we take
these all the points in our trainings
and the computer reduce our models
and using the operator inference and we
see that this both models
captures the pressure fields in the
given domain very well but
it's kind of deteriorates outside the
domain
of the training data sets but it still
is
can uh can very well approximate
the pressure field as well outside the
training set as well
and if you look up the fill so here the
velocity field as well and we if we
compare the error between the full order
models and the reduced order models
and the velocity field we also see the
error almost like a
less than one percent or less than one
percent here
the error of in between the reduced
models
and directly obtained from the operator
inference and the full order models
okay so here we have shown so far that
how we can
tell our operator inference for
encompassing flow and we can make use of
the knowledge of
the algebraic equations in our learning
process
and we can get a like very efficient uh
reduce on the models for incompressible
flows directly from the data set
so here i will jump a little bit how we
can really combine operator inference
with deep learning and this is our
some of our preliminary work in this
directions and how we can make use of
these two worlds
as well so what we know in operator
inference is that
we need to know the full knowledge at
partial differential equations
and so that we can make use of this
information in learning
however there are many scenarios where
we do not have the full knowledge of
all um the full knowledge of partial
differential equation or partial
differential
equation which we know which way which
may not characterize the whole
dynamics of the process so
then what we can do is split the the
dynamics into two times
two terms so f of v and r of v and
f of v the term which can be think
which we already know about the process
so which we know from the physical laws
or by experts
for example in the reactor models we
typically
happen to see this arrhenius kind of
terms for example or
if you are working with incomes of flow
then you know there is a compressibility
condition and this kind of knowledge you
know
about about the process and there is
some more terms which is rfa which i
like all these terms and which is a kind
of hidden dynamics or unknown terms in
the dynamics
and one of the typical example which we
can think of is a friction term in the
robotic sum
and the there is no concrete way how we
can really model
the friction terms in the robotic sum so
but we still know how the robotic sum
comes and for example there is a
classical mechanical systems but this
mechanical system may not
really describe the whole dynamics of
the robotic sounds
so then we can split into two parts so
and to this one
moreover if you look from the simulation
software
side then as we as we discussed before
that we can collect the data from a
software
and and we can build the reduce order
models directly having
access to a discretized model but we
need a full
knowledge of partial differential
equations or underlying partial
differential equations which
will describe or where the data come
from however
in these softwares they are also if you
has a complicated
process then there of course there are
small tweaks and error correction terms
which
we actually are not aware of these
things and
or is not possible to put in the
discretized model
and then they then there is a
some kind of a mismatch between the
passive differential equation
and the data which you collect from the
simulated software
and therefore it can also fit into this
category so
you have the some good knowledge of
partial differential equation but still
there is some correction term which you
are not aware of it
so how we can get a reducer models or
models directly
from uh from which or we can build a
model which will describe the full
dynamics
where we only know the partial knowledge
of the systems
for simplicity uh i assume this f of v
to be
a quadratic form and
why we make this simplification and
there are some supporting arguments
here which i will put across and these
are the
some some arguments which are
are as follows so first is that most of
the dynamics or the many dynamics
which we see or governing equation which
are qualitative and nature
and typical example for example navistox
you will also see in the fischer's
equation which
describe the dynamics of a gene and
which are also quadratic in the nature
moreover what is also possible is that
we can do
hand engineered variables we can define
the hand engine variables in which
dynamics are qualitics
and this is a philosophy of lift and
learn so if you have
if you if there's a dynamics is given by
a more complicated nonlinear systems
then it is possible to make a hand
engineered variables
and on those variables dynamics will
which
dynamics will evolve quadratically and
so people who are not really familiar
with the lift and learn approach i have
some
one example for example you consider a
non-linear system which is
in this form so you have x dot is equals
to minus x plus e of
x and e of x is kind of a non-linear
term
and so how we can write into quadratic
form is
by by lifting so you what we do is
introduce a variable g
and e which is e to the power of minus x
and if you take the derivative of it
then you
have this form and if you do the same
algebra of it then you will get this g
dot
is equals to h g times of minus x
plus g which is also a quadratic so
and then if you write into lift so
initially you have only one variable x
and but now you have the two variables
but
the beauty of this this form is that the
dynamics is now
the in the quadratic form so as i said
it
they are also possible to make hand
engineered variables and
in those those variables quadratic the
dynamics will evolve quadratically
and therefore we we by some kind of a
simplification or without loss of
generality in fact in some cases
we assume this quality form and
so now once we have this quadratic form
so
still we have this r of v and r of v one
of the thing is like uh
you can interpret this r of v as a
residual which you cannot resolve by
either by the quality form or the prior
knowledge and which are come
somehow derives the hidden dynamics in
the process
so what we do is we can make use of the
regional networks and the regional
networks has
this following architecture so this is
the regular networks is kind of also the
name suggest is a residual and it's only
learned residuals in the networks
so if you and the residual is
kind of learned by the by the network
and and
this is kind of enforced by this big
connections
and it has shown a lot of powers in the
computer reasons
moreover it has the residual networks
has a very nice connection with the
dynamical system how we integrate
dynamical system for example
explicit euler request euler schemes or
kind of schemes and it this all uh
integrating schemes has a strong
connection with the regional networks
and we want to use these things in
learning dynamical processes
and moreover you can think of residual
connections
as a adaptively refinement of your
solution or the features
so if you have as a
network goes deeper and due to the skip
connection
what you are doing is you are matching
this function close and close to
the the the velocity field or the
derivative of the velocity phase
and therefore you can actually add the
residual blocks
to refine your solution space again and
again without restarting the
optimization process which i will
show you in the next slides so inspiring
by these all uh facts we purpose a
the linear quadratic regional network so
you here
the one term is a linear term one is a
quadratic term and then we have the
residual terms which launch the residual
of residual dynamics in the process
so as i said it there are a lot of
advantage of the residual networks and
the one of the thing is
which particularly is very interesting
is the
is a loss landscape and typically
neural networks are high dimensional
optimization problems
however due to the skip connection which
we have seen in the residual networks
the loss length scan becomes much more
smoother and the training also becomes
much more smoother here
and again the layers as as i described
in the previous slide that the
layers can be seen as a refinement of
your solution so
we can add the layers in the course of
optimization process
without restarting the whole
optimization process from the scratch
so this this is why this kind of
connections can be used
in into learning dynamical process in a
very adaptive
adaptive way so here
we have tested this this approach to two
um biological examples they are not
large consistent but they still
exhibit the the the characteristic of
learning dynamical processes
so here we have the two
the first example which come from the uh
from the neurology which describes the
the
the neural dynamics in the more
simplistic way
so what we we do is we take 10
time series from the different initial
conditions
and we built the networks and the
residual
linear quadratic residual networks and
we checked the
the the predictive capability of the
models under the new condition
from the or from the unseen data sets
and we have observed that these
um this models which we get it they are
much more robust
as compared to if you do the fully
connected
neural network and this residual or
linear quality gradual
networks tend to perform much better and
also the training also becomes much more
smoother
even with the less number of data sets
and the other example is again from the
biochemistry which actually determines
the dynamics of the
the yeast glycolysis and which actually
involves seven
species and for this one also we have
taken the 30 different initial
conditions
and to test the models the learned
models
under the unseen data sets and we also
observed that
that the linear quadratic residual
networks tend to
perform much better and also has a very
good
compromise between the ground truth and
the learned dynamics
and here we do not have the full
knowledge about the process but we learn
the whole the residuals from the
residual networks here
and this this brings to this
brings me to end of my talk
so what we have seen is uh in this talk
the learning reduce our models for
nonlinear system directly from the data
in the operator inference framework
without having access to discretized
models
and but this is globalized by the fact
that
the knowledge of partial differential
equations in norm
we have also tailored the operator
inference framework for incompressible
navy stocks equations
and in the towards the end we have seen
a
linear quadratic residual kind of
network which allows us to
learn the hidden dynamics which we may
not fully know
then this is kind of inspiration between
the lift and learn and
also form the residual networks
and there are a lot of ongoing work and
the one of the things which we are
looking into is a non-uniform time
series
so far in the operator inference we
assume that the data is giving at the
uniform sample time but uh
but is not the case all the time for
example in biology you will not get the
data at the regular time interval and it
can be irregular or non-uniform time
interval so
to to tailor this kind of approach also
for non-uniform time series
we have not discussed um the noise in
the data set so
of course if you get a from simulation
then of course there's no noise but
if you want to also refine your solution
or the models
using experimental data and then
experimental data will
have some some noise and therefore we
have to
make use of like proper tools
for for the noisy case missing
and corrupted data sets we are again
this is very common if you are working
with an experimental setup
and we are also doing some real world
application of this approach to learn
processes in the chemical engineering
and we are strongly collaborating the
other departments at our institutes for
this one
and with this i would like to thank you
for attention and
there are some references which are
presented in this work
thank you so much uh dr coyle for the
great talk i
really enjoyed it um personally i i
think the same thing
it's the same thing for other audiences
we do have some questions in chat room
let's start from the boxing
question but the boxing um the question
is answered by
peter already but if if not please
omit yourself or ask the question again
boxing if you are still here
yeah i see you're there can you hear me
yeah
hi it's my answer i
i i don't know i i i wonder if it's true
the number of differential equations of
the model
okay so boxing's original question was
how is
the order of reduced auto mode reduced
model defined
okay so
um it is as bit also said its number of
differential equation of the models
this is also defined and so how
how many um how many differential
equation you need to
or you can also see the the dimension of
the state vector
so the for example
the here is x and if the x lies in the n
dimensional
then generally we have like n
differential equation and
if it's in the reduced space and which
is
the if the x hat
is lies in the n-dimensional or
r-dimension then
this also actually the number of
differential equations you have it
so this is how you can save the order of
the system
uh okay thank you yeah okay sounds good
okay
let's move on to the next question next
question is
uh uh from zhao
and he asked if we don't have any
knowledge
um on pde even partial partial knowledge
can we use neural net to learn the
reduced automotive or
if our prior knowledge of high fidelity
pde
is wrong can the neural net correct
the prior knowledge by learning process
through some study
for example some correction terms
yes this is actually the in the last
part of the talk
and of course this kind of networks
allows you to learn the residual and if
there is
you don't know correctly the partial
differential equation then it can be
correct by the residual network
and in the both example what i showed in
the last two
from the biochemistry
and we do not have full knowledge or any
knowledge about the partial differential
equation and we learn directly
from the network and do you get the data
from
experiments where do you get the data
you know here we have simulated data
sets here
we do not have the real experimental
data at the moment
simulated data okay okay next question
is from you're welcome okay
next question is coming from terrain um
very nice talk pawan
what types of venos number did you use
in your numerical test
how would do the operator inference
framework
in an under resolved turbulent regime
yeah in our this example we have venous
number 100
i i must say that we have not tested our
operating influence so far for trouble
and regimes or turbulence or
so this is like we are still looking
into
in turbulence and see how far we can go
with it but
yeah well i would say that we have not
tested in the extreme cases so far
yeah i i guess i'm sure you will get
there soon um
turbulence region okay the next quest
okay
let's next question is coming from
longchan
thanks for the very nice talk in my
experience we use regularization
regularization
when the optimization problem is
ill-posed
where we need to make additional
assumptions for the solution
you you mentioned that you do
regularization
because your optimization problem is
conditioned
can you give some more detail on that
the regularization
so we we have tested two kind of
regularizers so one is techno
regularizers so we
just regularize with the norm of the
solution
and one more which we also do is
on the svd best regulation which is
typically done in the dynamic mod
decomposition
as well so you for example
let me go to optimizing problem okay
let's say here so
here for example you have this d matrix
which might be in condition so what we
do is
we take the svd of this matrix and
truncate the smaller singular values of
it
this is also one way of regularizing so
but yeah there can be a various many
more but we have tested these two of
two kinds of regularizers and it works
both
these regularizers works almost equally
good
in in our experience
okay um thank you next question is
coming from
brenda ing thanks for the talk pawan
given your proposed architecture assumes
the decomposition into
h quadratic a linear term
and all residual term did you
confirm whether the quadratic linear
residual effects are being
captured by the constituent residual
meaning is the structure actually
increasable
or the effects are not captured the way
that you were
expecting thanks okay
to answer this this this question is
very nice question
um
we have tested these things so if the
dynamics are
governed exactly by linear and quadratic
term um
then actually you will see they
interpretability there
however if if the dynamics are not
governed by lean and quadratic term and
there's a residual terms
and the residual terms is a kind of
hidden and you don't know what kind of
residual it has it
then the interpretability becomes a
little bit harder
but however you can still see the
dependency on the linear and quadratic
term how strong it is
so if it is strong then
you have very little uh
or they they this more residual which
you need to learn and the network will
be small
and then you see there is a dynamics is
heavily depend on linear and quadratic
term
so in that sense it's more interpretable
but
if if there is a weak dependency on
linear and quadratic term and the
residual dominance then
it becomes hard the interpretability
becomes becomes harder
okay brenda you can actually use this
for effect discovery in a sense if so
very nice
right yes yes yes basically awesome so
you can see the
the how the dynamics goes and also to
learn also to see the effect of these
terms
and i mean of course is a kind of a
networking processor so it's not like
you you make a network and then you you
will have
all the interpretability so you have to
go an iterative way and learn it
so if you want to get more
interpretability there
okay thank you next question is coming
from
david chambers uh he asked
what is the relationship between rom
accuracy
and number of snapshots in the training
set would you
have difficulty if the system has a
high degree of intermittency
okay i'm sure if i understood the last
part of the questionnaire correctly
but the accuracy of reducer models and
snapshots i mean
the
i mean there is a i think i would say i
would really say that
the quality of training set really
depends so
the accuracy of reduce or the system
depends on the quality of
training data sets so and though the
dynamics you want to capture
so and if the training data set does not
describe the
dynamics the overall dynamics very well
then the reduced
order model will also will not
generalize to all the scenarios
in our experience okay and
so i mean can you okay intermittency
means that there can be
short intervals with less variability
combined with
long periods of relatively low
variability okay yeah
i think nice question but i i i must say
that
we have not that this is all the
variability that
if you go if you take more data set with
the
uh with the longer periods
and low variability so we have not
tested so i i
it's a little bit hard for me to say
anything concrete in this direction
okay okay okay um i mean i i have a
following question
about that dave um you know in
traditional reduced
although as you increase the basis size
um in reproductive case
your accuracy of the rom has to you know
reach the full
model uh accuracy right
yes do you see that in this framework
you know the in the operator inference
framework i'm very
curious about up to
some level uh i wouldn't say that you
need to go to machine precision but
it can go very low until the numerical
issues hits you
so but we can go up to like 10 minus 10
order
accuracy with respect to original model
but afterwards when the regularizer or
the ill condition becomes
dominant and solving this optimism
problems becomes trickier
if you if
if you take more and more bases actually
what you're doing is
you are actually also increasing the
condition number of the optimization
problem
so there will be like a kind of uh going
in the opposite direction here yes yes i
i got you
okay all right um the next question is
coming from boxing again
if the residual is non-deterministic
how could your methodology be applied i
noticed that it is
listed in the future work can you
illustrate a little bit more
how would you tackle that
um i mean of course i think if
if there's a i mean we don't
consider like a stochastic as this is
for at the moment the thing
so we we say that there is a noise
in the measurements but still the
process is very much deterministic and
the noise is actually coming from the
sensors
or the measurement errors
so but we do not look into the proper
stochastic
systems and get into the
learning stochastic system of the
networks
um yeah this would be this what i would
say
at the moment and we are not looking
into stochastics but in the
more into uh more
into deterministic case assets well at
the moment
okay um the next question is coming from
brenda
are you familiar with the universal
differential equations
generalization of neural odes by chris
rachael vlad is this a pure
neural network or are you using as
joints part of the back propagation
are you familiar with the neural od yes
yes i am familiar with it
well we are not using any
more sophisticated things what they use
in
in the neural ods we are doing in the
very classical
networks there we are not using the
adjoint of the
back propagation at the moment no
okay um
how okay next question is coming from
soprano
how do you estimate the dimension of the
worms
so this is actually done on the looking
at the
k of singular values so which i plotted
like one of the examples
so here you collect your data set and
you look at the you take the
single value decomposition of your data
set
and look at the decay of single values
and
to the order of reduced system which
determine how much energy which you want
to capture
so here for example which choose the 10
which is goes here and
which already captures almost 99.99
of your energy or
energy present in your training data
sets
so this is how you can determine order
of for the dimension of reduced order
model
by looking at the decay of singular
values
great um my following question on that
would be
i mean it's related to what uh terrain
asked
if the reynolds number is really high
then the
solution becomes advection dominated
you will not have a common growth with
decaying fast enough
then how would you deal with that
so so far we in our framework we have
assumed that
the linear projections gives you
sufficiently reduction in the state
dimension
but if you becomes convection dominant
problems then
linear projection does not work anymore
and
we have to look into nonlinear
projection and this is some of the work
for example
kevin carvik is doing and we we are
looking
into doing for example convolutional and
best
um reduction which i kind of you can
think of
known in your projection of the state
but we have not
really looked into very strong convex
diffusion equations i would say right
but
as i said like in the operator inference
so far we assume there is a sufficient
like the easier reduce order model
sufficiently small
by linear projects themselves right
right
well we have a recent work extending
kevin kalberg's work
um by achieving some speed up i mean
kevin's original work
you know was was not that fast and we
extended his work to accomplish the
actual speed up so you might want to
take a look at that um yeah thank you
we look at this list okay i don't have
any more questions
in the chat room but that doesn't mean
you cannot ask questions you can
unmute yourself and ask questions
directly
okay the xiao asked another question can
we use
this reduced auto model for data
assimilation or
optimal control if so then we will
define a cost function or
some kind of quantities of interest that
means the video studio model has much
less output dimension
to consider will it be easier to build
one
difficult i i
i wouldn't say that this will be easier
to to construct reduce order models but
however you can still improve your
the accuracy of quantity of interest
little bit
by the post processing or by solving an
additional optimization problem there
but i in my experience i wouldn't say
that
it will it will make the building
disorder models
are cheaper or easier
okay thank you um any other questions we
we are
five minutes after the um you know
scheduled time
but yeah any other questions
uh rob i just asked is the
neural i think the residual case
what will your lq residual map to if you
are missing 3 or w
2 yeah how does it handle incomplete
information
um we
at the moment we don't say that we are
having the missing so we assume that
the sequence is at the regular time
interval
if it's missing then we at the moment
not doing any kind of
processing so that's why i listed in the
one of our online work we are
looking how if if there is any uh
missing data set in the sequence then
how we really
make use of it still compares to the
signal so
at the moment we are we do not have a
methodology which
actually handles the missing v and u
okay i hope that answered your question
rob
um i i think we
kind of have to end here um
well if you have further
more questions please directly email um
you know pawan i i i'm sure he doesn't
mind
it sure i'll be happy to receive
something
okay awesome okay so with that let's
thank our speaker
dr goyal for the great talk uh thank you
so much
welcome our pleasure okay uh
thank you so much and um in for the next
ddps
seminar i think we do have a another
seminar next week so please uh stay
tuned
um otherwise at john
let's call the day thank you so much
it was a great talk thank you it was
our pleasure to give talks okay we look
forward
to hearing from you more about getting
something
yeah okay thank you
and then have a a very nice day i think
it's very early morning still there so
you have a still complete day
yeah yeah
okay all right all right thank you very
much again
and then for hosting and inviting no
problem
oh um okay send me send me a slide
sure sure i'll send you those slides
okay
okay thank you okay bye-bye